Dans "Pourquoi on dit",
je vous raconte ce quise cache
derrière les expressions
de la langue française.
Alors abonnez-vous et n'oubliez pas...
que je suis cloche...
Salut les Épicurieuses
et les Épicurieux.
Savez-vous pourquoi on dit :
“Être au 7ème ciel” ?
quand on est profondément
heureux.
Pour savoir pourquoi le bonheur
se loge à cette altitude,
Il faut remonter à l’Antiquité.
À l’époque, les astronomes ont identifié 7 corps célestes
au voisinage de la Terre.
Et à l’image de notre planète,
chaque astre est supposé
être entouré d’une sphère
transparente, son ciel à lui.
Le premier ciel est celui de la Lune.
Puis, viennent ceux de Mercure.
Vénus, le Soleil, Mars, Jupiter
et enfin Saturne.
À l’époque, les amoureux
montaient au 3ème ciel.
Celui de Vénus,
la déesse de l’amour.
Mais pourquoi s’arrêter
en si bon chemin ?
Avec le temps, le nombre de ciels à franchir
pour atteindre le bonheur a augmenté
et ce dernier s’est établi dans le 7ème,
celui de Saturne.
Rien d’étonnant finalement car le chiffre 7
est aussi hautement symbolique dans beaucoup de religions.
Dieu aurait aussi achevé son œuvre au 7ème jour.
Les pèlerins à la Mecque doivent faire
7 fois le tour de la Kaaba
et le chandelier hébreux
possède 7 branches.
Chez les Québécois, en revanche,
le bonheur est beaucoup plus accessible.
Lorsqu’ils sont heureux,
nos cousins d’outre-Altlantique
ne vont pas au 7ème ciel mais disent
qu’ils sont aux oiseaux.
Ça fait aussi rêver !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisserun pouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater abonnez-vous et activer la cloche !